hey I just want to say it's really great
to be working with you okay I'm thrilled
too especially we're working with Al
Pacino right I mean it's crazy oh did no
one tell you what yeah I couldn't make
it well what what gentlemen oh what's
going on
I can't make it don't worry huge I'll be
there he's good Mastermind scene 12 take
one and action you erase people's
memories with tap water we just want to
know why well have you considered that
I've already told you but erased your
memory with tap water Detective
it's a good one it's a good line
Mark that take okay cut
thank you detectively suppose you're
supposed to be the good cop in the
sunlight and will that make you the bad
cop no
not right
wrong
I'm not good or bad I'm like a mix
you understand mystery cop like a third
new kind of cop you don't know with me
mystery cup you don't know
you want a back rub
no like a good car
friendly that's okay thank you relaxing
you don't want to hurt innocent people
do you this is the only move I do bad
cop okay cut
crime may pay for the interest
well that'll kill you
tired cop
we got ways to make you talk pal there's
nothing you could do to me that hasn't
been done a thousand times before
really there's nothing you could do to
me that hasn't been done
really
hasn't been done a thousand times
that's a refreshing
you have everything you need to solve
the crime you just haven't looked close
enough I'm single still looking for my
huge Beverly D'Angelo
tell us what we need to know there's
nothing to tell
it's not a wig
oh I had detected
them close to your badge you can have it
buddy hey can I ask you a question real
quick
but lunch is here
did you say dressing on the side for
your chicken
yeah yeah he did
yeah
it is just swimming and dressing it's
like they were making a point
bad cop
if we really get our tap water from
reservoirs shouldn't the level be
dropping okay as we go that's not the
line cut
you're saying if a moth wants to see my
sweater so bad
let it happen
okay cut oh I'm in character that's not
the line I have a back story he has a
thing for moths huge let's do this right
action how big of a bite would a moth
take let him have still not the line do
you know what I don't know what's going
on here okay but I'm a professional I
can't work with this six foot obviously
insane John Ritter looking person
pretending to be Al Pacino it's
ridiculous I'm not pretending to be Al
Gino Al Pacino is pretending to be me
I don't have an agent I don't look like
John Ritter you look like a little boy
that just blew a horn to Mark the
beginning of a Civil War reenactment
foreign
how's your skin son I like my aids to be
presentable
you have a glass of wine with lunch you
sound Dusty
wait what is that it's also said a woman
oh lesser known would you say Attica
ouch good working with you Tim always
seriously thanks for getting me the work